dieser baum ist jetzt ihr zuhause
wir sollen sie sascha nennen ihren namen
will uns die 21 jährige nicht verraten
denn sie lebt illegal auf zwölf metern
höhe in dieser arche vor einem halben
jahr ist sascha im hambacher forst
eingezogen das leben hier oben kann für
sie schwere folgen haben
das ist eine protestform dass wir hier
leben wird mich also natürlich ist es
für uns schön aufbäumen zu nehmen und
ich genieße es total verbunden zusammen
mit der natur aber wir machen das sie
als direkter aktion als protest und
nehmen in kauf genommen zu werden und
sind uns den bewusst ich bin mir
trotzdem ziemlich sicher dass uns weh
tun wird und bin ich deswegen umso
wichtiger dass wir zusammenhalten weil
es wird er wahrscheinlich nicht nur sein
wir werden hier waren sondern auch wir
werden verhaftet und wir kommen ins
gefängnis ins gefängnis dafür dass sie
mit ihren baumhäusern den wald schützen
wollen schützen gegen seinen eigentümer
den energiekonzern rwe
sascha und ihre mitstreiter haben sich
in den bäumen professionell eingerichtet
sommer wie winter leben hier oben rund
30 aktivisten um ein zeichen zu setzen
erklären sie uns sie betrachten den
braunkohleabbau als großes unrecht dass
sie verhindern wollen
nur wenige sind bereit sich offen zu
zeigen oder mit uns zu sprechen
im links im bild hat sich deshalb eine
maske aufgesetzt und erklärt uns sein
weg geht dann plötzlich an wird jeder
wald gerodet als 40 anderen menschen
vertreten hier und seit 40 jahren wird
auch die gesundheit und das wohlergehen
der der anwohner gefördert durch die
emission von der - und das ist völlig
legal
das was wir machen dass wir den wald
besetzt halten und dass wir versuchen
den wald vor der zerstörung zu schützen
das ist verboten
in einem selbst gedrehten video
dokumentieren die besitzer ihren kampf
um die bäume hier stürmen sie auf
sicherheitskräfte von rwe zu die
versuchen ein baumhaus zu räumen die
lage eskaliert die grenzen zwischen
protest und gewalt sind fließend der
energiekonzern pocht auf sein recht er
habe die volle politische rückendeckung
für den abbau der braunkohle in seinem
revier noch für jahrzehnte sagt rwe
die leute die im hambacher forst auf
bäumen sitzen werden dort nicht lange
bleiben können denn der tagebau ist
genehmigt
klimaschutz ist ein ziel von
energiepolitik gleichzeitig muss
energiepolitik aber auch dafür sorgen
dass ein dicht besiedeltes und hoch
industrialisiertes land wie deutschland
zuverlässig und auch preisgünstig
erschwinglich mit energie versorgt
werden kann
doch braunkohle sei eine schmutzige
energie argumentieren sascha und kim
wenn die bundesregierung weiter auf die
sitze werde sie ihre eigenen
klimaschutzziele niemals erreichen
diese mine ist der größte co2 produzent
von europa und das co2 geht nicht nur
uns an sondern die ganze welt aber ich
vertraue nicht darauf dass parteien was
ändern und ich glaube es ist zeit für
unsere zukunft selbst in die hand nehmen
dort ist ein symbolischer kampf denn der
größte teil des hambacher forst es ist
längst abgerundet der tagebau ist ein
gigantisches 400 meter tiefes loch das
in den letzten jahrzehnten nicht nur den
wald sondern bereits zahlreiche
ortschaften verschlungen hat tausende
menschen mussten umgesiedelt werden
bisher konnten weder klagen noch das
engagement der aktivisten am ende die
braunkohlebagger stoppen
erst 2050 will die bundesregierung aus
der braunkohle aussteigen
trotzdem wollen sascha und kämen nicht
aufgeben
für sie geht es nicht nur um den
braunkohleabbau ihr ziel ist es gegen
ausbeutung zu kämpfen
ausbeutung von mensch und natur beides
symbolisiere der hambacher forst mann
hat einmal diesen wunderschönen weit her
der wo alles lebt und wo alles grünes
und irgendwie harmonisch ist noch
unternehmen hat man die mine einfach ein
unglaubliches nicht das ist so das ist
für mich ein total guter ausgangspunkt
zum kampf der sich gegen vielmehr
richtet
ein kampf auf zeit die sicherheitskräfte
von rwe beobachten alles was am und im
wald passiert sascha rechnet damit dass
auch ihr baumhaus bald geräumt werden
könnte
doch darauf seien sie und die anderen
vorbereitet